[Music]
we are here together as one
do you feel like you're coming out as a
witch maybe I mean
yes yeah it's been such a journey and I
kind of had an Awakening and had so many
questions and was so curious I was very
much on this idea of like a spiritual
Brigade and I kind of wanted to figure
out who they were specifically so I can
be more intimate with them
um and I definitely thought that I
always take a moment to connect to
Spirit and the easiest to me is my
spiritual Brigade because they're always
there with you it's just like a really
empowering grounding protective thing to
be able to do consciously okay let's
call this bad boy
does anyone
there it is come here come here come
here come here
whoa it's sort of like Vanessa sees dead
people connecting with the supernatural
in the 98-minute documentary dead hot
Season of the Witch streaming on 2B the
former High School Musical star travels
with her bestie musician Gigi mcgree to
Salem Massachusetts to find out all
about the Paranormal I feel like some
people are going to say this one's a bit
Practical Magic meets Ghost Hunters
how would you describe this journey I
always say that the only way to heal
ancestral trauma is to shine a light on
it and Witchcraft has been painted as
this demonic thing through film for
years and I want to like take away some
of that taboo and like show you what
Practical Magic looks like
um and hopefully like Inspire someone
out there to like practice or feel seen
or
um you know like open their eyes up a
bit more because there's so much so much
from start to end of this film is
manifestation what do you feel like
you've manifested in your own life I'm
like my relationship my home my
career like there's there's so much as
long as you're really specific yeah why
not always come when you expect it or
want it but it's always going to come
back in some way I mean there is a lot
of Truth in manifesting so you
manifested your relationship with calm I
mean I I definitely was like these are
the things I'm looking for and he showed
up he had checking those boxes
congratulations thank you by the way are
you in the thick of wedding planning
right now you know it's it's a it's a
lot more than I expected it to be I'm
I'm still the very beginning the very
Basics I'm getting married that's all
that's all that matters I am guest of a
ghost okay Vanessa gave me an exclusive
tour around a special Haunted Mansion
experience in New York complete with
tarot cards and magic potions her next
ACT Conjuring up a return to this fan
favorite franchise bad boys bad boys
what you gonna do you've got bad boys
four the fourth installation the
franchise coming out so where's Miss
Kelly fitting into the mix was fighting
crime and taking down the bad guys with
Martin and well you know she's always
ready to roll with them
um things definitely take an unexpected
turn in this one but guaranteed a lot of
laughs and a lot of action
[Music]
have you already finished production on
it no I actually am going to Atlanta
tomorrow to start filming there's such
an iconic Duo and it's so much fun like
even being in the room with them when
we're rehearsing and they're saying
they're lines because it's just they got
a chemistry that is undying yeah it's
beautiful to be a part of bye
[Music]
thank you